do a lot i wonder if a lot of people
from the city do most people in the cia
like keep it hush-hush after they leave
a lot of people do
um especially if so there's a number of
paths you can take when you leave a lot
of people
contract and go right back in so they
just keep everything under
because there's no reason for anybody to
know um
and then some people when they leave
they leave into jobs where
they already have something set up like
i have a i have a friend who
you know left right into like she you
know
uh networked with somebody and there was
an interesting job that came up so she
left the cia to go directly into the job
she's had ever since
no reason for her to roll back her cover
people who stay overseas also don't roll
back their cover because it's tricky
if they are like stationed overseas and
then leave the agency
while still overseas they don't roll
back their cover
because they're that's just a tricky
situation for them
um but you'll see i mean there are
enough people out there that even with
cover rolled back if you look on like
linkedin
you know there are certain signs you
know people say i worked for the usg
you know like yeah the us government you
know very generalized
yeah thing on there so they probably
have their cover rolled back
but um they're careful not to put
details and we're only allowed to say so
much anyways you know
even with coverroll back all your
language has to be approved it's all
very generalized
nobody knows what you're talking about
if you're trying to get a job
so you know how how specific
is that when you're like officially
leaving the cia like
i'm curious talking to you and andy like
how specific are they with what you are
and aren't allowed to talk about and how
often do you
are you communicating with them like
because he mentioned that every time he
does something
public he has to like have a
correspondence or something
right so you're supposed to um it's like
anything written is supposed to go
through
a review board and then they look at all
your language
that relates to the agency um
i mean like my resume they picked over
every single word and it came back with
all kinds of marked out things and then
replacements like
it just has to be very general you can't
have any specifics
the biggest concern is revealing like
sources and methods
so we don't ever talk about like
specific places we went to
or talk about like specific
methodologies that we use
in you know specific trade craft um
so yeah when when you're generally out
and about talking
you just kind of try to stick to the
rules because there's only so much
review that they can do anyways so you
just
try to police yourself make sure
you're not divulging anything important
right
now i mean that's a huge a huge change
that you made
from being a spy in the cia
or uh you're a target or a kinetic
target no no no
not kinetic they did not blow people up
oh you didn't you didn't blow people up
operational officers
you were one of the nice yeah that was
the nice one
the one that was gonna get somebody to
come and buy you a drink oh yes exactly
exactly to be our friend and spy
obviously
so yeah so like what was that like was
it something
in you that happened like was there some
sort of
some sort of event that made you make
that decision
becoming a spy to motherhood and family
life
so once we were pregnant
we got pregnant when we were overseas
and then we came back right before we
had the baby like a month before we had
the baby
um andy was moving into management so i
was always a very behind the scenes like
i wanted to just specialize in what i
did i was not interested in moving up
the ladder or
any of that but andy was moving into
management
and just like i i'm guessing any place
else like
the higher you rise the more hours you
work
we were back in the dc area there was
tons of
you know commuting time was just huge
and um and we were still trying to live
our life where we like we had one car
and we had like our
you know our little apartment like our
kind of minimalistic
life but it was getting harder and
harder because he was having to go in
early
and stay in late and then i'm stuck
alone with the baby
after i'm working too we're trying to
balance daycare and all the things that
parents everywhere go through um
and i think for for me
because i hadn't really done that
critical thinking at that time because i
had
i was in the mindset of like i have
arrived and this is what we're going to
do and this is what life looks like
but andy was like we can do better than
this like
i am not he was not where he wanted to
be
he wanted to be home with his son he
wanted to
be on his own time um and so he was the
one that kind of planted the seed of
like let's go
and i think after several months of
having our new baby
and having no help because we had no
family members in the area
we were just on our own trying to
balance everything
i was like you know moving close to
family sounds good
so that's what we decided to do and he
we networked into a private company
and started our new life in florida yeah
that's amazing what's it been like in
florida compared to everywhere else
you've been
so i grew up here and funny enough
andy had to convince me to come back
because
um i spent all
of like my high school and college years
here so i went to like university of
south florida i went to florida state
university
um trying to leave i was like i'm going
to be a professional and i'm
getting out of here like i'm going to
where professional people go or whatever
um so it was this big thing and i was
like oh i mean i got to d.c
i got to the cia so when he was like
let's go back to st
p i was like no no i was like we can go
to colorado
like let's really yeah like why not
florida why why were you so against
it it was really just the idea of coming
home
where i felt like i had achieved so it
was my own personal issues that i had
i needed to work through right like i
felt like i have achieved and now i'm
taking a step back somehow beneath you
yeah
but since i mean i'm i'm glad like he
he had traveled so i had traveled the
world but not really the united states
which is kind of funny he had traveled
the united states
so he said the first christmas i brought
him home it's christmas time
there's lights on the palm trees it's 70
degrees you know in december
and he was like from the first moment he
was like this is it
this is paradise um and so
because he has seen so much of the
united states for him
to say you know saint pete's the place
i was like okay like i'll i'll do it and
my parents lived here my sister lives
my entire mom's side of the family lives
here okay so i was like
lots of family st p's not so bad
now that we've been back a while now
we've been back several years
um i'm really happy i'm really happy
that he had the idea to come back and
i'm really happy that i listened to him
because he's very smart so well don't
say that you actually
you actually you actually regret moving
back here and you really can't wait to
get the hell out of florida
we don't want anybody getting the wrong
idea about florida true
do not move the same petersburg florida
sucks go to texas
oh yeah totally everything goes in texas
so just go there i heard texas is so
much better than florida
beautiful no they got they got they got
the new law the open carry without a
permit
my gosh i've been i am just right about
that that's so funny
yeah they were like there's other states
too like what other states
yeah not that it matters because i'll
never see the gun i guess
well texas has the least gun violence
right
isn't that true i don't know i think it
is i heard it somewhere
i don't know that's crazy